Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going to
explain an American comedy-heist film called
“The Perfect Score”. Watch out and take care!
Kyle is a normal high school senior aiming to get
into Cornell University’s architecture program.
He knows exactly what he wants in life but the SAT
is standing in between him and his dreams. In
the opening scene, he is in the examination hall
looking through the answer sheet that is telling
him he is just an average guy. After the examiner
asks them to stop writing, Kyle looks around and
locks eyes with Anna. She has a 4.0 GPA and is
the second-highest-ranking student of the school.
Which makes it surprising that her answer sheet
is completely blank. In the background, it is
narrated that students might be good at different
things; some are better at singing and others
at sports. But according to the SAT, everyone
has to pass a “standardized” examination that will
determine their future. The narrator thinks it is
unfair, so he calls the SATs, a Suck Ass Test.
The results are published and Kyle scores 1020,
as opposed to the minimum 1430 that he needs to
get into his preferred college. He complains to
the principal about the absurd method that the
SAT uses to test the students. According to Kyle,
math equations and complicated social scenarios
are not the way to determine if a student should
get to go to their dream college. The principal
receives hundreds of students after every test,
complaining about how unfair it is. But
all of them have one thing in common;
their score is less than what they
need. For him, Kyle is just one of many,
so he dismisses the conversation after giving him
lousy advice that he delivers to every student.
Then, we are introduced to Matty, Kyle’s dumb
best friend, and his right-hand man. He has an
average GPA of 2.3 and is not so good at studying.
Matty’s girlfriend Sandy is a freshman in Maryland
college so his only goal in life is to join
Maryland and hook up with her one more time.
Kyle tells him that he lied to his parents
about scoring 1430. The poor fellows even
bought him a cake to congratulate him. His elder
brother Larry is a bigger idiot than Matty.
He lives on top of his parents’ garage that
he claims is a different house because it
has a separate phone line. Larry accidentally
blows the 0 from the candles and jokes about
how he got a 143 SAT score back in his day.
Later, the friends go to the Educational Testing
Service center, commonly known as ETS to complain
about the unfair system. However, the receptionist
stops them because many students like them come
to complain about their SAT scores every day.
As they are asked to go away, a girl proudly walks
inside the building. She is the talk of the town,
and the dream of every high school guy, Francesca.
She walks into the building like she owns it,
which is untrue because her father is the one who
owns it. That evening, Kyle and Matty drink while
thinking of a way to ace the next test. Matty
calls his girlfriend Sandy but a man picks up
her phone. The call ends in only a second but
Matty registers that she is cheating on him.
He blames the SATs and suggests they
steal the answers for the next test.
Kyle laughs it off at first but starts to take the
idea into consideration. The next time they meet,
he asks Matty if they were to “borrow” the answer
sheets from ETS, how would they go about it. Matty
suggests they ask Francesca for help since she
can enter the ETS headquarters anytime she wants.
Moreover, she is an adrenaline junkie and will
do anything to have fun. A heist is right up
her alley so the guys are positive she will
join them. When she is briefed about the plan,
she immediately agrees. Then, we are introduced
to a star basketball player Desmond. He plans to
join St. John’s university and play for their
team. Even the dean is happy to have him.
However, he has to take the SATs and score
at least 900 to get into college. Desmond
is excellent at math but that would still not be
enough for him to make it. Kyle and Matty are in
the school’s bathroom when Kyle reveals that he
told the school topper, Anna, about their plan.
He has a crush on her but refuses to admit it.
Matty freaks out because she is one of the nerds
who will probably tell the police but Kyle assures
him they are fine because she refused to be a part
of their plan anyway. The two had thought they
were alone in the bathroom and are surprised
when the school junkie Roy appears in one of the
stalls. Kyle and Matty hope that he is too high to
understand what they said but the guy is used to
being highly alert even when high. At last, they
have to reluctantly include him in the plan.
At night, Anna returns home to see that her
parents have called a professor from Brown to
help her get into the university. She is tired
of them pushing her to do better because doesn’t
even want to go to an Ivy League university in
the first place. Since she zoned out in the last
SAT, they have been pressuring her more than ever.
The next morning, Francesca, Kyle, Matty, and Roy
go to the ETS headquarter and devise a plan for
a simple heist. Francesca provides them with
the uniforms from the mailroom and makes them
enter the ETS floor without any problem. They
had asked Roy to stay outside but he somehow
enters the building on his own and includes
himself in the plan. Then, the group separates
and goes around the office trying to figure out
which cabin has the SAT answer sheet. Meanwhile,
in the school library, Desmond meets Anna and asks
her to help him to prepare for the SAT. However,
Anna herself is stressed about the test and is
scared she will mess up again. She thinks of
joining Kyle on his heist and also tells Desmond
about the plan, hoping it would help him.
Back in the headquarters, a woman finds Roy
snooping through her office. She is about to
report him but he uses his poor flirting skills to
make her stop. Even though his pick-up lines are
lame, she seems to enjoy them. In the other room,
an office worker calls Kyle and hands him the SAT
question sheet. Kyle is left stunned but it
turns out that the man mistook him for a worker
in the copy room. He asks Kyle to print two copies
of the paper and hand them back. Kyle happily goes
to the copy room but accidentally shreds the paper
instead of copying it. They are back to square one
because of his stupidity. Following that, Anna
meets Kyle and asks to be included in the plan
along with Desmond. Kyle had lost hope but
now that Anna wants to be a part of the plan,
he thinks of another way to acquire the
paper. He collects the blueprint of the
building from Francesca and asks her to
get all the security codes. Anna spies on
headquarter’s security guard and finds out the
routine of the rounds he takes every night.
Then, they decide to meet at Kyle’s brother’s
place to go over the plan one last time.
While Francesca is coding something, Roy helps
her, proving that he is a technical genius. Kyle
keeps it in mind because they might need his
help in case of an emergency. Then, he explains
the plan in brief. Although it is a little shaky
and success isn’t guaranteed, the group agrees to
help him. The next day, Roy, Desmond, and Anna
stay outside the ETS headquarters to keep an
eye on the building’s guard. Meanwhile, Kyle
and Matty enter the building and wait until
the top floor is cleared. When all the employees
go home, Francesca distracts the security guard,
giving the two an opportunity to run to
the roof. From there, they use a rope to
enter the topmost floor and get to the room
where the papers were supposed to be kept.
However, it turns out that the floor has been
renovated since the blueprint was made, and they
do not know where the papers are. They refuse to
return empty-handed and start brainstorming other
ideas. Kyle remembers that the man who ordered him
to print the papers also has a copy on his desk.
They go to his office and start looking around
with their torchlights. Just then, the security
guard steps outside to smoke. The flashes of their
lights are clearly visible from the guard’s view
so Anna quickly calls the group to alert them.
They turn the lights off seconds before the guard
sees them. After that, they finally find the room
they are looking for but the answer sheets are
nowhere to be found. As the last resort, they try
to open the computer but it requires a password.
They call the technical genius, Roy, for help.
But they will have to distract the guard before
letting him in. This time, Matty comes up
with a plan and calls his friend to deliver
flowers and alcohol to the guard’s name.
When the guard is busy receiving the gifts,
Roy runs inside. Along with him, Anna and Desmond
also come, thinking that they might be of help.
Then, Roy predicts the password using a picture
on the table. The group finally gets their hands
on the question paper but to print it out, they
will need three more passwords. They lose all
hope and are about to return but Kyle refuses to
give up. He says that they can solve the answers
in the time before the guard comes for a routine
round. Everyone else laughs at him because if they
could answer the questions, they wouldn’t have
to be there in the first place. He reads the
first question out loud and Anna answers it
instantly. She couldn’t answer the questions
in a classroom because of stress but when she
is with them, she can easily solve the paper.
Desmond is also excellent at math, so he and Roy
solve the math portion of the test while Anna
and Kyle solve the verbal. Lastly, Francesca
and Matty are told to watch the lobby.
While waiting, they get into a conversation
about Matty’s girlfriend Sandy who doesn’t
call him anymore. Francesca tells him that it is
over and asks him to get over her but Matty gets
irritated by the comment. Suddenly, she kisses
him and claims that he would be a good boyfriend
to whoever he loves. A while later, they get done
with the questions and finally get ready to leave.
Roy tries to climb up first but the others
pull him down, noticing that he has stolen
supplies from the office. Desmond makes him
put them back in their places while the others
continue climbing up. Anna and Kyle easily make
it to the top but the security guard comes for
the rounds before the others can escape. Desmond,
Matty, and Roy are in the safe zone but Francesca
is about to be caught. At that moment,
Matty decides to come in front of the guard
to save her. While the others climb to the
rooftop, he surrenders and is arrested.
The next morning, Francesca steals money from her
father and bails Matty out. They reunite and kiss.
Matty doesn’t want to take the SATs anymore
because he thinks he is better off not going
to college. He wants to take a year off to find
out what he wants to be in life. Anna is also a
different person from who she was yesterday. She
stands up to her mother for the first time and
declares that she isn’t going to Brown. Following
that, the group gathers and Kyle hands them the
answers. However, Anna refuses to take them
because she wants to go to Europe for college.
Desmond and Roy also do not want it because Roy
wants to start creating online games and Desmond
has gained confidence after solving the questions
during the heist. Francesca, who already had a
perfect SAT score has no use for the answers and
Matty is also not taking the test. At last, Kyle,
too, refuses to use them. Because they are
of no use now, Roy hands them to his junkie
friends who ace their test because of it.
A few months later, Desmond takes the retest and
gets into his desired university. Matty starts
to audition for acting roles while Francesca
sells her first novel. Kyle also does fine on
his re-test. Although he doesn’t get into his
preferred college, he still dreams of being an
architect. Anna, on the other hand, moves to
Europe for further studies. She starts dating Kyle
and frequently returns to New York to meet him.
Lastly, Roy sells a hit online game making
millions of dollars. In the ending scene,
we see him living his best life.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thank You for watching.